mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
polizeigewalt in minsk am rande der
demonstrationen engagieren sich mutige
menschen in einem gesamtscore um mit
volksliedern gegen den machthaber und
seinen brutalen repressionsapparat an zu
singen und an der ausstellung junge
kunst in winterthur sind jetzt schweizer
nachwuchstalente und die neuesten trends
sind kunstschaffen zu entdecken
[Musik]
wie kommen hat den kulturplatz wir
machen heute station in einer kathedrale
des industriezeitalters in der halle 53
in winterthur an diesem
geschichtsträchtigen ort zeigt sich die
junge schweizer kunst und will gesehen
werden
[Musik]
doch bevor wir hier in den kosmos der
jungen kunst eintauchen zuerst noch ein
blick auf die aktualität in minsk in
weißrussland ist es in den vergangenen
tagen zu erneuten protesten gekommen
gegen das diktatorische regime von
präsident lukaschenko unter den
demonstrierenden gibt es auch viele
kulturschaffende die ihre eigenen mittel
gefunden haben um gegen den machtapparat
anzugehen sie singen nämlich gegen ihn
an
der jubel von zehntausenden ist der
freie chor von minsk bei jedem
protestmarsch mit dabei mit ihren
auftritten wollen diese künstlerinnen
die friedliche protestbewegung
unterstützen
sie singen alte volkslieder und aktuelle
protest songs und keine festnahmen zu
riskieren singen sie immer nur zwei
lieder dann lösen sie sich auf ihre
maske nimmt die chorleiterin galliner
nicht abwägen corona und um nicht
erkannt zu werden
wir protestieren gegen gewalt und
folterungen gegen lügen des
machtapparats gegen wahlbetrug gegen
diktator gegen ungerechtigkeit und
justizwillkür
die aktionen der opposition werden fast
immer aufgelöst durch brutale
polizeigewalt
die 40-jährige chorleiterin galina
flieht vor bewaffneten einsatzkräften
der freikorps geht nicht nur auf
demonstration
täglich dritter in verschiedenen
wohnblocks darmstadt darum galina hat
dieser tage kaum zeit für ihre kinder
viele anwohner trauen sich nicht mehr in
die innenstadt wegen der polizei gewalt
menschen in dutzenden innenhöfen
versammeln sich zwischen ihren häusern
um gemeinsam zu singen musik ist zum
untrennbaren teil des protestes geworden
auf welcher seite die anwohner stehen
zeigt die rot-weiße flagge der
opposition
wir haben gesehen wie die leute rund um
den wohnblock eine wache aufgestellt
haben sollten die einsatzkräfte
auftauchen werden wir sofort gewarnt
deswegen bin ich jetzt ruhig ich bin
froh dass in menschen täglich solche
straßenfeste stattfinden
noch im sommer hätte die freie
dirigentin galina es nicht für möglich
gehalten dass so viele menschen in
belarus auf einmal einen regelrechten
drang nach singen empfinden werden
deswegen bezeichnet sie die proteste als
singende revolution
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es gibt durchaus leute die nicht mehr an
veränderungen glauben in meiner umgebung
ist es umgekehrt
diese konzerte vereinen uns sie geben
uns optimismus und kraft dabei tauchen
hier immer wieder einsatzkräfte und
männer in zivil auf viele leute haben
angst überhaupt aus dem wohnhaus
rauszugehen
viele nachbarn wurden einfach abgeführt
und landeten im knast an geheimen orten
wie in dieser kirche zeichnet der
freikorps die protests uns auf die
kirche in belarus zeigt sich solidarisch
alle songs der opposition werden auf
einer cd gesammelt sie sollen in ganz
belarus kostenlos verteilt werden um
mehr landsleute gegen das autoritäre
regime zu mobilisieren
dreht der freie chor musikvideos sie
sollten die stimme des protestes
verstärken
deswegen wird auf unser team von ganz
oben immer größerer druck ausgeübt
besonders jetzt musikerinnen aus dem
chor werden entlassen oder bedroht die
chefs laden unsere leute zu besprechen
ein und fragen sie aus wer wir sind und
was wir machen
deswegen finden die aktionen immer im
verborgenen statt wie hier in der
minsker u-bahn vom musikalischen
flashmob erfahren die teilnehmerinnen
erst eine stunde vor beginn
wer zu spät kommt verpasst sie
[Musik]
diese gesangs veranstaltung werden immer
öfters angesetzt
unsere hoffnung ist verpufft mit blumen
und friedlichen aktionen für den
machtwechsel zu sorgen der nationale
streik ab dem 26
oktober sollte der nächste schritt sein
wir bereiten uns darauf vor
doch sollten beim streik viele nicht
mitmachen könnte das einen sieg für den
diktator lukaschenko bedeuten
davor haben die demonstranten angst und
um diese angst zu besiegen
dafür singen sie
[Musik]
ja wir sind zurück in der halle drei
flüchtige in winterthur und da bei mir
die zwei junger kunstschaffender wir
möchten die kinder erschossen
was trieb dort zum kunst machen große
frage gross ich ja ich denke das kann
man nicht einfach so schnell einfach in
einem satz beantworten sondern das ist
mehr das kühlfach und natürlich habe es
werfe beschaffen und zweiten
theologischen arbeit ist einfach eine
atmosphäre schaffen für die besucher das
gewaltdarstellungen himmelsdarstellung
das versuchen wir immer da haben einige
materialien wurden zusammen spiele zu
den zyklus zu bringen hatte warum sie
sind die kuratorin dieser ausstellung
was ist ihre einschätzung die jungen
künstlerinnen und künstler sind sie
politischer oder unpolitischer wie die
früheren jahrgänge
ich habe schon das gefühl dass sie
politisch sind als ich das jetzt so in
den letzten zwei drei jahren
festgestellt das ist vielleicht eine
neue dringlichkeit auch hat und ich
denke das sieht man auch wirklich in den
themen die hier behandelt werden wie ist
das bei euch sehen die reue aus
politische kunststoffen wie ja ich danke
kolleg als politiker für sich sicher das
thema der kunst jetzt explizit bei der
arbeit könnte man sagen es geht um
nachhaltigkeit publikum von architektur
seit 20 jahren wohnt eigentlich dazu auf
seite dass mit diesen ressourcen zu
schaffen und und war und dass man nicht
einfach eine blutbuche sondern mit
möglichst wenig eigentlich viel machen
da sind aber auch sie haben mir all
diese bewerbungen gesichter gibt es ein
thema das sie alle antrag also alle
antreiben ist jetzt vielleicht ein
übergriff aber es gibt themen die bei
mehreren arbeiten auftauchen das ist
wirklich konsumkritik taucht öfters auf
nachhaltigkeit die klimadebatte und man
sieht das an mehreren werken vielleicht
nicht auf den ersten blick aber je näher
man in die werke eintaucht
man sagen und ich denke darum geht es ja
auch es geht um eine künstlerische
position ganz herzlichen dank in die
runde
die jungens 2020 ist eine überraschend
vielfältige ausstellung mit politischen
wie poetischen arbeiten
[Musik]
in den usa tobt der
präsidentschaftswahlkampf und
gleichzeitig steht das land am abgrund
wie konnte es so weit kommen dass fragen
sich wohl viele von uns die usa ein
verrücktes landkreis
so lautet jedenfalls der titel eines
neuen buches geschrieben von einem
schweizer ehepaar das seit über 20
jahren in den usa lebt und arbeitet wir
haben ihren blick auf die usa
eingefangen
wofür wird ja stets dieses sternen
besetzte banner noch gerade in
verrückten zeiten
welchen titel also wählen für die nation
die hier im buche steht
ich erinnere mehrheiten gefunden
pointiert und damit vom ok das gut und
wenn wir jetzt gesehen was in diesem
jahr passiert das nur ideen die ohren
denn am english es ist wahnsinnig dass
ich eigentlich die amerikanisch welthits
titel entwickelt
damit das sagt ja dass ich nicht nur
negativ trend negativ
ambivalent trifft es eher davon zeugen
die alltagserfahrungen die adriana und
alfred mettler niedergeschrieben haben
sie zeigen ein land das zugleich
vertraut und befremdlich
vereint und gespalten ist
crazy geben
ihr buch hinterfragt was die
populärkultur oft besingt den american
dream
ein vergleich
[Musik]
das führt natürlich auch dazu gehört aus
mythos immer wieder gehört und den
vielleicht glaubt es geht es natürlich
von der liebe zum beispiel wo es härter
leben auf dem land beschrieben aber
nichts ist so wie es meinem vater
gemacht hat oder dass ich nur holzwerk
sie und dann ist man und ehrlichkeit das
ist mit dem ist menowin das hat man
schon oftmals besungen und das ist
eigentlich das was wie der bühnen
existiert
das land als verbindende nation
ja aber nur solange unterschiedliche
weltanschauungen ausgeklammert werden
wie die met das schreiben
im alltag würde ich sagen ist es völlig
das so dass man das aber gar nicht
aber jetzt nach besetzungs nacht hat
tausende ganz einfach über vieles und
retten
heiße themen nicht über politik
der heutige situation sowieso solche
alltagsbeobachtungen zeichnen das buch
aus sie lassen vom einzelfall aufs
allgemeine schließen und
veranschaulichen sowie die bevölkerung
tickt oft ist sie verhaftet in starren
denkmustern auch als folge des
bildungssystems
die ganze gesellschaft ist eine lineare
denkprozess um spaß
das zeigt sich zum beispiel dass die
meisten briefe gehört multiple choice
sind alte beschluss ist richtig oder
falsch und sehr viele sachen sind
entweder schwarz oder weiß gut oder
schlecht sie sind null oder eins sie
sind rechts oder links das zeigt sich
auch in der politik
er hat dieses denken verschärft donald
trump
teufel für die einen heilsbringer für
die anderen
sein leitspruch make melka kritiken
bedient nostalgische gefühle
[Musik]
die szene habe
die super league führen
[Musik]
dieses urvertrauen ist tiefer skepsis
gewichen
toms verwischung von wahrheit und lüge
fordert ihren tribut notieren die beiden
schweizer längst nicht alle wollen denn
auch der kritik der black lips matte
bewegung glauben schenkt
[Musik]
diese traditionelle hymne der black
community fordert gleichheit
ein anderes amerika hält damit aber auch
den american dream hoch und so zieht das
autorenpaar ein ambivalentes fazit
[Musik]
amerika das land wenn der druck wirklich
groß wird es bis jetzt immer zahmer
kraft und heizwerke nach oben tragen
das ist die mini hoffnung aber ich würde
jetzt nicht sagen das wird garantiert so
hoch es ist wirklich es ist wirklich vor
12 240 oder die usa ein verrücktes land
das jedoch selbst wieder alles
zurechtrücken kann wenn es denn zu sein
rückt krise
[Musik]
und wir sind zurück in winterthur bei
der jung kunstausstellung hier wollen
die jungen kunstschaffenden der schweiz
gesehen werden sie kämpfen um
anerkennung eine die das bereits
geschafft hat im fach schauspiel ist die
baslerin china haller sie wurde vom
renommierten magazin theater heute zur
nachwuchsschauspielerin des jahres
gekürt wir haben sie in bochum besucht
sich hingebungsvoll verausgaben und
dabei ganz bei sich sein
china hat hohe ansprüche an sich an der
spiegel die 33-jährige ist
ensemblemitglied des schauspielhauses
bochum nachwuchsschauspielerin 2020 und
für den theaterpreis der faust nominiert
wüster garten
sie hatte als ophelia überzeugt in der
rolle des hamlet sandra hüller zwei
frauen ein spiel auf augenhöhe
thalasso feder ist kein opfer niemals
dargestellt sondern eine starke frau
warum sie stirbt bleibt offen
wie geht es dir haben worum ich seine
frau spiele beruf der bewerber sich
umbringt und einfach zu altmodisch
altbacken nach und es ist mir wichtig
dass zu viele eine moderne frau ist mit
der armen frau heutzutage identifizieren
oder junge frau sich an identifizieren
wir machen uns rechnen mein impulsives
mehr aufs erste und ex tag ruhiger nein
danke die buchungs sicherung freier
qualitäts ideen dankt das muss ich auch
als qualität als fehler
iwanow am meisten zu ihrer eigenart zu
sich selbst stehen eine herkulesaufgabe
ihre mutter ist schweizerin ihr vater
von der elfenbeinküste
china wächst in der nähe von basel auf
[Musik]
redknapp war der für andere rinder oder
wenig freunde ausgeschlossen kommentare
für erwachsene
zu der gesellschaft unter ausschluss
hanif jeden fall spüren
die eltern trennen sich als china 14 ist
nach der matur folgt sie ihrem vater
nach paris studiert dort später
schauspiel dann in bern
man n 4 1 sie werde es als schwarze
künstlerin schwer haben wenn bochum
zumindest seit man explizit auf
diversität sind jetzt rund das langsam
das buch und das theater seit eigentlich
avantgarde sie uns ich bin nicht das
avantgarde ist ein ganz viele punkte
finsteren viel radikaler sie verstecken
sich noch hinter alte klischees einen
angst dass iris altbewährte publikum
einen grund aber warum also geht doch
qualität schlechter da wochen gegenteil
nicht nur einen großen bühnenrollen ist
aller derzeit zu sehen sondern auch in
mehreren filmen
darum ist mir immer noch nicht gesagt wo
die fähre ablegt warum hörst du johanna
ist angekommen
sie wünscht sich dass viele nicht weiße
nachfolgen und für sich selbst weniger
druck ich möchte mich nun immer mehr
wiese also ich mach dich macht mit lust
und freude rolle ago und irgendwie
specials erhole
aber ich möchte nicht nur persönlich
fertig mache ich mache möglich dass der
beruf mehr freute sich die hörer und den
haniels machen
das stelle okay das war definitiv nicht
hoffen ach ja einen weiteren kleinen
wunsch hätte sie noch
die schweiz spiele da würde ich mich
freuen wieder ein schweizerisches telgte
theater nach bochum
ich würde so ist da doch irgendwie
patriot
[Musik]
dresden
viele kreative orientieren sich an den
ideen aus der vergangenheit oder
arbeiten sich an ihnen ab je nachdem das
ist in der kunst so und in der musik ist
es nicht anders die alten legenden
direkt in bezug zu setzen mit den jungen
talenten
das ist die idee hinter dem projekt
times den mord trafen sich die legenden
baby can
[Musik]
johnny cash
bruder patti smith
[Musik]
alle verewigt im film archiv des
montreux jazz festivals
perlen daraus zeigt der veranstalter
sanio beim in einer konzertreihe namens
thales
timeless wie es eigentlich verschmelzung
ist vor dem roxy städtischen tempo
dennoch und das einbringen als legende
vorführen
juni mit der spitze jungen musiker und
bands die arbeit verschmelzen aus dem
klo sie musikalisch das war in jung
damals noch ohne maske jetzt steht die
nächste auflage von timeless an am start
unter anderem die blues rock band velvet
tust
unter singer songwriters apps bereit für
die begegnung mit den legenden von einst
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist ja das was ich
behaupte immer billiger und dessen
spencer sie werden an diesem abend ihre
eigenen songs spielt vielleicht auch ein
cover ihres großen vorbilds patti smith
[Musik]
und stehen
es hat mir sehr viel v bilder gehwege
und deutschland ist es so dass sie trotz
wollte eigentlich und hat sehr schnell
sehr gut mit der ich eine identifiziere
und auch ihr wird neben eigenen stücken
ein kammerspiel die virtuelle begegnung
mit dem idol macht doch ein wenig nervös
ich bitte euch nicht über lüge sie
beging
[Musik]
das sei nicht vom gewinnen aber es gebe
auch das drin
das wird immer flüge und ich bin
natürlich sehr wichtig einen abend lang
die bühne live teilen mit den stars auf
der leinwand
das schürt träume selbst einmal am
legendären festival spielen zu können
[Musik]
eine große große durchspielen
vielleicht in ein paar jahren in not
nichts ist ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hier in der halle 53 in winterthur
können sie ab donnerstag bis sonntag die
jungen schweizer kunst auf sich wirken
lassen
wir melden uns nächste woche wieder dann
ziehen wir uns zurück in die familie die
letzte bastion sozusagen erst recht in
diesen zeiten und gleich jetzt folgt die
serie der report der markt kommen sie
gut durch timmermann
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos
[Musik]